[Musik]
vor 9 Jahren sind Beatrice und der
Marcel Buchholzer ab auf Kreta mit Mitte
[Musik]
Wochen
sondern im ruhigere Sissi und sie sind
schon wieder am züngle
alles klar
was machen
[Musik]
2014 sind Tricks und der Marcel auf
kretainimiertwohnung
er auf der Suche
[Musik]
Moment
[Gelächter]
e
[Musik]
zum sie wiederfinden durch Tricks hilft
bin Rentier telepatin aus der Schweiz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das Thema ist abgeschlossen
[Musik]
ich kann mich immer noch nicht ganz
erholen
Garten investieren
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ung
[Musik]
zurück zum zügler die griechischen
zügelmannen
[Musik]
gemacht
aber so ist gut das passt für uns Baby
wunderbar und das ist genau das haben ja
ja
[Musik]
zweimal pro Woche
nee Greta ist natürlich schon sehr groß
von West nach Ost sind es gute 260
Kilometer
auch die Geschichte die geht ja zurück
zurück bis zu den minoren es waren ja
die ersten die ja ja die hier waren und
sind drei 4000 Jahre
viele lieben Freunde
gibt es hier auf der Insel ca 30
Millionen
beim nächsten Urlaub wenn ich kommt
könnte ich immer zählen
[Musik]
Tricks hat die neue Filz
mich Stress möchte wenn es nicht schnell
vorwärts geht ich bin
die Sachen erledigend und jetzt geht's
aus dem so wahnsinnig schnell
langsam oder das geht mit meinem
extremer
jetzt
langsam langsam langsam
das ist im Griff
vor vier Jahren Operation ein Narkose
hat Mama
bewegen schaffst du ja wahnsinnig viel
so aber
nicht richtig funktioniert
[Musik]
da werden wir
der Rest ist Fußarbeit
[Musik]
3250 Jahre
der Olivenbaum der wächst glaube ich
0,75 mm oder 0,5 mm pro Jahr
so pro Jahr dann kommst du auf diese
Daten ungefähr 352 Jahren
nur zu Beweis da ist noch eine Olive ist
unglaublich mit 3.52 Jahren
und beide produziert
schönes Bäumchen
ich finde das beeindruckend
ja es geht relativ wenig
60 70 80
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Fragezeichen
verabschieden
Herzinfarkt gestorben noch 22 Jahre mit
ihrem Mann ist Tricks für ein Tag auf
der anderen
irgendwie
wahnsinnig schlimm für mich
gestorben ist
sehr schöne dort gesehen
der hat einfach nicht aber es klappen
muss
[Musik]